[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
this
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
hey guys uh my name is don jacobs
and i'm a member here at the table and i
just want to thank you so much for
uh meeting with us tonight um i hope
that you've had a good week
um and that things are running smoothly
for you um
but if not we totally understand
this is an amazing place to be to
help try to get um just
re-centered refocused
to be encouraged no matter where you are
to connect with people that love you
dearly and deeply
and to meet you where you are so hope
that you can just tune in
relax and be able to
be prepared for this next coming week
because we can be here to support you
and wherever you are
i do have a couple announcements for you
uh the first one
is for the e3 conference that speak that
is coming up
um this next month it's going to be for
three dates
um october the 22nd 23rd and 24th
and this is a conference that if you're
not familiar with um it
is a place where you can learn more
about
folks who are lgbtq and their faith
journey
and where the church kind of fits in
that um
so this is something i've attended the
last time it was around about two years
ago
um i got to not only meet some amazing
people but i got to meet a lot of people
that were really just really trying to
search for answers kind of where they
are
and thankfully we are a part of a church
community that's very affirming
um but we also are very connected
to a lot of people that are still not
sure where they fit on this entire
conversation and we're still being
involved in conversations
outside this church um about where they
are
so this might be a good place for you to
equip yourself
um if that's something you're interested
in be sure to check it out it is going
to be online
um also um the second announcement is
for our welcome to the table class
uh this will be on october the 11th
and so save the date for that um come
and join
learn more about about the table who we
are
and you can sign up in the comments uh
that will be below this message
or this screen and um you'll just be
right after service that particular
sunday
so now i want to introduce you to one of
our
members of the teen meetup group
his name is preston and he's going to be
sharing with
us the prayer for us tonight so preston
take it away
and the prayers and the praise and the
words and the wonder
we are given enough joy to live each day
and the justice for the oppressed and
the unexpected generosity for the loss
we are given enough compassion to use in
service each day
and the promise made to all and the
mercy offered to each
for a given enough grace to share each
day
thank you preston so much for sharing
that with us we're really glad to be
with you all
today and we hope that our time together
with worship is um a bright spot in your
week we hope that it brings you peace
and joy and some creativity
so if you guys want to sing along this
is a new song so you may not know it but
it's called springtime
by chris renzima
[Music]
you're the resurrection
that we waited for
[Music]
all the praise is yours
is
your love is
[Music]
you restore my soul
we will sing a is song but hallelujah
[Music]
and like
i will
[Music]
oh
hallelujah
[Music]
is
like springtime
wow thanks mindy maggie that was that
was awesome
um before i get started
um i just wanted to acknowledge what a
beautiful day we're having today
and um i just felt like reading a
scripture
from psalms 19 was very fitting so i'm
going to read this real quick and then
i'll
play a song the heavens declare the
glory of the lord
the skies proclaim the work of his hands
day after day they pour forth speech
night after night they reveal knowledge
they have no speech they use no words
no sound is heard from them yet their
voice goes out
into all the earth their words to the
ends of the world
[Music]
his holy name
sing like never before
[Music]
oh my
i soul your holy name
[Music]
the sun comes up it's a new day
dawny it's time to
sing your song again
whatever may pass and whatever
lies before
[Music]
sing like never before
oh my soul
[Music]
i'll worship your holy name
your name is great and your heart
is kind for all your
goodness i will keep on
singing
10 000 reasons for my heart to
find
[Music]
bless the lord hold my soul
o my soul
worship his holy name
sing like never before
oh my soul
[Music]
our worship your holy name
and on that day when my strength is
failing
the end draws near and my time
has come still
my soul will sing your praise
on
[Music]
you are a way maker miracle worker
promised keeper
not in the darkness my god
that
[Music]
a is worker promise keeper
not in the darkness my god
that is who you are
you are here you're moving in our midst
i worship you
you are here you're working
in this place i worship you
i worship you
you are here you're turning lives around
you are here commending every heart
i worship you
cause you are a waymaker miracle worker
promise keeper
not in the darkness my god
that is who you are
you are a way maker miracle worker
promise keeper not in the darkness
my god that is who you are
that is who you are
that is
[Music]
and bless the lord hold my
never before
oh my soul
i worship your holy name
lord i will worship your holy name
lord i worship your holy name
thank you gary well good evening
everyone grace and peace welcome to the
table
and i just want to name whether you are
rich or poor
gay or straight like a long time
believer in christ or
just very new to all things
um god and christian and spirituality
and all that
um we are just glad that you've joined
us so thank you thank you for being here
with us tonight
uh so the title of my message is the
endless lessons
of manna and barbecue and
we're gonna be in exodus chapter 16.
so uh so last week we looked at the
story of
moses encountering god in the burning
bush
and we discussed basically how that
wasn't
simply a snazzy god experience for the
sake of
uh you know giving moses goosebumps and
giving him a a cool god moment
rather it was it had a purpose right it
was a call it was a commissioning
a sending of moses
so basically moses he was called to lead
the israelites out of slavery in egypt
and so over the next 12 chapters or so
that's that's basically exactly what
happens and if you're familiar with the
story you'll remember
like all the plagues that befall the
egyptians and then the parting of the
red sea and how the israelites
cross over on dry ground but then the
walls of water
crash on the egyptian army even if you
haven't read it in the bible maybe
you've seen the
handful of movies that have uh kind of
unpacked the story
so it's it's a moment of i mean it's a
lot it's a moment of profound
deliverance
um freedom kind of breakthrough but uh
alas
you cannot stay on the proverbial
mountaintop of victory forever
eventually we all must descend into the
valley of testing
of maturing so the whole kind of caravan
travels three days into the desert
and there their animal skin water
pouches run dry
the people begin to freak out god then
provides water
they travel another week maybe two
and they reach the desert of sin
uh here's a picture that i think scott's
gonna
put up there uh as you can see not a lot
happening um wouldn't call this prime
vacation
mean you know area
it's just uh yeah it's not a great spot
so it's in this wilderness
where they begin to run short on food
and so we pick up the story there this
is verse one uh in chapter 16
the whole israelite community set out
from elim
and came to the desert of sin which is
between elim and sinai
sinai on the 15th day of the second
month after they had come out of
egypt in the desert the whole community
grumbled
against moses and aaron you'll recall of
course moses leader aaron
is his um uh i think brother-in-law
and kind of sidekick so the whole
community's grumbling against them the
israelites said to them if
only we had died by the lord's hand in
egypt there we sat around pots of
meat and ate all the bread we wanted
uh later rabbis would comment on this
and say do you notice they said
that we sat by the pots of meat and ate
bread
by the meat bread and they kind of
described it like i wonder if it was
that the egyptians were eating the meat
and they of course were the slaves so
they ate the bread but you know at least
they were there
they at least they lived in the land of
luxury so they're kind of looking back
on their past isn't this what we do we
look back with the kind of rose-colored
glasses
oh the good old days you know uh we sat
around pots of meat and ate all the
bread
we wanted but you you have brought
us out into this desert to starve
this entire assembly to
death now in a sense this passage
um really kind of encapsulates the
entire story of
israel's years of wandering in the
wilderness because yes it does in fact
turn into years
they have left the land of oppression
they have
left a regime of enslavement
and and we could say that their problem
is that they
are not grateful i can imagine a pretty
good sermon about how the israelites
were
grumbling rather than grateful with a
little gigi alliteration
grateful preachers love that stuff and
that would uh certainly that would be
true right that's definitely there
um it's never bad to remind us human
beings
to be grateful it seems our minds um
we're pretty attuned to the negative
you know we're kind of scanning the
environment for what's wrong and
and going poorly uh but instead i don't
really want to go there tonight i said i
want to go
i'll call it i want to go a little
different direction maybe even a little
deeper
and i want to ask the question like what
has gone on
in their past uh what wounds
have occurred to their minds in their
souls
that would lead them to say completely
unreasonable things like you have brotha
brought us out into this desert to
starve us all to death
like imagine your moses all that you've
done
all that you've put on the line for them
like yes
that's it wow you got me guys i have
risked life and limb
i can imagine moses saying do bring you
to this moment and here we are all gonna
die that was my that was my plan my
little joke
good one huh like sure enough god's done
all these miracles you know partying the
sea and all yep to bring you right here
to die like come on
of course not this is ridiculous um but
of course it sort of begs the question
like what is going on why are they doing
this
so i think we get a hint of the answer
in not simply the sheer fact
that god provides for them as you'll see
he does
but how how he provides verse 4
and the lord said to moses i will rain
down bread from heaven for you
the people are to go out each day and
gather enough for that
day in this way i will test them
and see whether they will follow my
instructions
so uh how does this go well we find out
pretty quick jumping down to verse 13.
that very evening quail came and covered
the camp
so he gives the meat and of bread and in
the morning
there was a layer of dew around the camp
when the dew was gone thin flakes like
frost on the ground
appeared on the desert floor when the
israelites saw it they said to each
other
what is it but they did not know what it
was
moses said to them and that is literally
what mana means
like in hebrew it literally means like
what is it like hey
uh bill grab me some more what is it and
that's what man means
moses said to them it is the bread the
lord has given you to eat
this is what the lord has commanded
verse 16. everyone is to gather as much
as they need
take an omer for each person you have in
your tent that's about like nine
cups nine to ten cups or so uh the
israelites did as they were told
some gathered much some little and when
they measured it by the omer the one who
gathered much did not have too much and
the one who gathered little did not have
too
little everyone had gathered just as
much as they needed
then moses said to them no one is to
keep any of it until morning
however some of them paid no attention
to moses
they kept part of it until morning but
it was full
of maggots and began to
smell so moses was angry with them
verse 21 each morning everyone gathered
as much as they needed
and when the sun grew hot it melted
away what is going on here
is god trying to teach the israelites
to be grateful trying to teach them not
to grumble
yes you could say that but is is that
the main
thing what is their problem what is the
the deep wound what is it that they lack
um and this will recur again and again
and again throughout the entire book of
exodus i'll sum it up for you in one
word
trust god
is adamant that they learn
to trust if you're a note taker
for those committed few who are still
you're in your homes you're taking notes
god bless you and so you can write this
down
the invisible wound of abuse
is a lack of trust the invisible wound
of abuse is a lack of trust you see when
we read stories like this it's of course
very easy to pile on the israelites
look at them in their crazy talk look
look at how
rude they are look at how god does all
these miracles like over and over and
over but there's
they're just constantly in a panic like
omg come on people
how can you be so dense but what are we
missing
they aren't acting crazy at all they're
acting quite predictably
remember they have spent their entire
lives
in the context of abuse and
mistreatment and so the deep truth that
has been
ground down into their psyches
is that you must scratch and claw
and fight for survival and if you rely
on anyone it is yourself
and only yourself you can trust you
that's it now you might say
uh that is terrible for them
and yet you might also think like well
but i mean
i'm glad i'm not like that and yet i
wonder if perhaps
this invisible wound uh extends you know
a lot
further than we often think i mean as we
just discussed it's like fairly obvious
in um you know those who were raised in
a situation
of neglect or abuse
right we would struggle to trust
but what if to a lesser but not
insignificant degree
this is the invisible wound of countless
others
perhaps to some degree all of us
i think for example just of myself like
i was raised with
um no particular abuse or
acute neglect in my childhood i had um
pretty dang good parents and uh good
friends i had
uh a good church community
um right and these people weren't
everyone wasn't perfect or something
like that but it was good
you know um i've no complaints no no
authority figures ever abused me
so i should be a shining example of pure
and open trust right
nope i think if you ask those who like
know me well would you describe brett as
a super duper open trusting person
i think they'd say
and what they're kind of hinting at is
no uh no
but if you ask me like bro where what's
the matter buddy like where'd that come
from
uh i i don't know
i think i just kind of picked it up on
my very
human journey see it seems that to be
human
is to be fragile and vulnerable
to be human is to be sort of like the
israelites wandering through the desert
and our reaction to that vulnerability
is that we build walls of emotional
resistance to and distance
from others rather than bridges of
connection
and healthy dependence on others we
build walls of emotional resistance
to and distance from others rather than
bridges of connection and healthy
dependence uh on them
uh now i say healthy dependence because
of course there is such a thing as
codependence or over dependence right
this is
uh where a person is so desperate for
approval so
hungry for love that they have really
little to no sense of identity um
no sense of self outside of their
connection to another person like even
if that person treats them
uh horribly so just be clear i'm not
talking about becoming
codependent what we're describing here
is is this sort of
space this middle ground um between
on the one hand kind of an unhealthy
codependence and
on the other and almost cynical
i will not rely on others i will not
trust others i will do it myself i do
not need anyone
i'm fine on my own and
uh you know by the way when you adopt
that kind of posture that actually may
serve you somewhat well
in like in some ways you'll probably be
very employable
for example like you're going to be
super responsible um you know get things
done i am
reliable i you know reliable person it's
on me
but your friendships will suffer if
you're married
your partner will suffer and as you
approach or enter into the second half
of your life
you will increasingly have the sense
that what you thought was a healthy
skepticism
of others a healthy lack of trust a
healthy
independence ju was actually
um rooted in the soil of fear
in past pain and i think that's
that's the key right it's it's rooted in
this soil of
fear fear of being hurt
so what on earth can we do we can
partner we can mutually
rely we can learn to mutually
depend we can do things together right
stop saying i can do it on my own
we can ask for help without feeling
guilty
we can begin to learn to lean on
others we could say things like i could
really use some support right now
um some of you would never say that in 1
billion years
i'm kind of one of those people i could
really use some support right now oh
gosh
i get the chills just saying that out
loud
um what else we could we could turn
toward god in others
right rather than away it's kind of this
posture of
of of um a heart posture turning toward
god and others rather than away uh so
coming back to
to our exodus passage uh you can see
that really this is the genius of again
not simply
that god provided manna for his children
but
how he provided it right it was it was a
partnership
it was an exercise in trust it was
a a nudge for this broken people
to turn toward god because every morning
he would provide and every morning they
would gather
just what they needed just what they
need
in trust learning to form bonds
of healthy dependence
uh there's a beautiful beautiful episode
that just came out
on uh netflix from the show
chef's table there's maybe like five
fans of this show
and art i don't think this is like a big
hit but i love this show it's amazing so
their latest season
um is their barbecue edition so they're
like telling
kind of basically stories of famous pit
masters from all over the world
uh and what was kind of cool is i was
delighted to find that the opening
episode
was about a texan uh what uh
named she has a great name i think it's
tootsie
tootsie my kids are there watching this
they probably laugh
dude tootsie tomanettes i think that's
how you say her last name
uh and scott has got uh an image here
of tootsie uh she's amazing
she is greatness as you can see like
she's a can you just get kind of
a feeling of a self-reliant woman here
got the shovel
the fire in the background because
that's how she barbecues right like
legit wood fire i mean she's
she's awesome uh and so in this episode
it's it's a beautiful story
really well done um in the first two
thirds of the episode it's basically a
story of her self-reliance
and um the way chef's table goes it
really tells the
it's the background story of that
particular um
you know chef or uh person pit master uh
so i really i thought that would be the
arc
you know is like here she is she's just
an amazing person
uh and in the first 30 minutes there's
like lots of scenes you know of her
talking about her life of hard work and
um how uh like decades before her
husband had a stroke
and so she works full-time as a janitor
during the week at the local high school
and then friday night literally all
night she barbecues
and she's the lead pit master at the
number one rated barbecue joint in texas
and she's doing all of this at age 85.
like she's just she's amazing uh and
there are tons of shots so you can tell
how they're telling the story
because there are lots of shots like
like the
the image of her the fire like lots of
shots of her standing alone
you know looking off into the distance
with that
kind of grizzled texas look you know a
certain
um kind of uh look in her eye you know
determination uh and in every image
she's alone like every single one
but then about two-thirds of the way
through the episode a shift
happens because
um so the back story is that because the
success of it's called snow's barbecue
that's where she works
um in the last 10 years or so tootsie
has become just
like very famous people want to hug her
they want their picture with her the
famous tootsie you know um
but she was always like that i mean
she's old texas you know so she's just
gruff
and distant and like please get away
from me just let me cook
you know let me do my thing uh but then
a few years back
tragedy uh struck her her husband white
finally passed away in hospice care and
then just a short time later her son
hershey
also died from brain cancer and
this emotionally it just completely
destroyed her
because her identity had been built
on caring for others right she was the
one
that people relied on uh
but no one but um
but she relied on no one else right she
was the one who cared for others
and suddenly there was no one to care
for
and and truth be told um
really no one even to care for her and
it was just too it was just too much to
bear
um and so she begins to i mean she's
just grieving
but of course like friday night she's
there working all night because it's
just her life you know just work work
work
and um she said this this is a line from
the episode she said it was about three
weeks four weeks
after hershey's funeral it's her son and
she said the people
the people had heard and she says this
all with like tears in her eyes and it's
amazing you'll hear what these people
say it's like
kind of just you know almost not
noteworthy like they're just kind of
being nice
but for her i mean she'd never had this
in her life
she said the people heard and there were
so many people who come to express their
sympathy to
me said i had a gentleman come up to me
and say i'll always remember
your son because he gave my two children
each
a silver dollar another person said
i'm so sorry for your loss
she just says this with tears and
amazement
in her eyes and a small little like
smile on her face
because she can't believe that people
care about her and they care about her
pain
that they want to like walk with her
and this is where the shift happens the
next scene
a lady comes up to tootsie while she's
like tootsie's barbecue and busy
and the lady says i'm gonna give you a
kiss on the cheek and as i'm watching
this i was like oh no
tootsie's gonna punch her in the face uh
but no
scott has this picture our grizzled pit
master
who leans in closes her eyes
isn't that such a beautiful picture of
of trust
and vulnerability she just closes her
eyes and she receives this kiss
and for the rest of the episode the last
start of the whole episode
is it's basically to see hugging on
people
receiving their kisses i mean this is
strangers
kisses and support and you're watching
it like
what has happened to grizzled
old self-reliant texas tootsie she is
turning into a big
softy and the last words in the episode
it literally closes with this
what's he said through my whole life
i just always felt very independent
but after white and her she passed away
i learned
that i had to call on someone to help me
i feel a lot of support when i'm down
and out
i feel a connection i really do
they're holding me up they're walking
with me
now of course the truth
is that our ultimate
deep trust
cannot be other people
because well people are people
and they will let us down if i could i
can imagine someone
you know kind of criticizing this
message with like hey
people have hurt me and so i want to
speak to that let me just kind of rip
that band-aid off
um yes that's true people are people
in fact um even i i bret pastor brett
will let you down
if if i haven't already um just wait
it's
it's coming probably next year or two
we'll relate enough
uh it'll happen right my wife maggie uh
all of your church leaders
um we just go down the list your parents
your spouse your best friends they will
let you down
at some point they will hurt you they'll
break your heart they'll break your
trust
and here's the thing before you start
bemoaning their weakness just remember
you're going to do the same to them
which is why learning to trust other
people it's often
our first almost baby steps
into trust but ultimately ultimately
we must graduate into a deep
trust in god like the israelites we must
learn at a soul level
to trust to rest
knowing that god has got us
i think immediately of jesus prayer
in the sermon on the mount um he taught
at the end of the lord's prayer
that says our father who is in heaven
holy be
your name uh your kingdom come your will
be done on earth as it is in heaven
give us this day our what our
daily bread what's that what's that
naming
we are learning to trust
right and it's not just about literal
food it's this it's this heart
posture of okay
deep breaths god has got me and i know
this season we're in
um some of you have been to hell in back
i've heard some of the stories
of on top of of covid and everything
we're going through but but then there's
layered on top of that is just personal
tragedy
of um you know parents getting cancer
some of you yourselves getting cancer
like
um folks are have been going through it
some of you have experienced um
just a painful loneliness in isolation
and and what i just want to name um is
that this
this is there's there's a invitation
hiding
in that there's an invitation learning
to trust
to rest knowing that god
has got you this is why the spiritual
life
is not one of independence
but interdependence
learning to trust learning both to
hold others and perhaps more importantly
to be held by god to be
sustained so turn towards
ask for help knowing that god
will provide just what you need the
manna
won't run out i promise you that
can i pray for you lord jesus
i lift up every person listening to my
voice right now
and i ask that as a community
yes we would learn to look to one
another
but ultimately lord teach us to look to
you
help us to be that people of deep deep
faith knowing that you will come through
that you will provide that the manna
won't
run out god whatever that mana is for us
whether it's energy financial provision
[Music]
a job actual food
shelter birthday gifts for our kids
mortgage payment god whatever we're
having to trust you for
and may you make us a people who learn
to trust to have that deep wound healed
the life-changing name of jesus i pray
amen
one two three
every moment of my wondering
never changes what you
see i've tried
[Music]
my
i'm needing you to
[Music]
i
i'm
[Music]
i
twelve
[Music]
you are
there's
[Music]
i'm trusting you
oh thank you so much for uh joining us
this evening
if you're in need of prayer or support
at this time if you wouldn't mind just
kick us a
message in our facebook page we'll have
one of our leaders reach out to you
and for all of those who support the
table financially
thank you your gifts will empower us to
carry on this work and give
us the uh to the organizations like five
lobes
pantry in saxi and for those of you who
would like to support us
you can go to the website at
thetable.com and select
giving at the top of the page
don't forget about the e3 conference
that's going to be happening on
october 23rd 22nd 23rd and 24th
and then the welcome to the table class
is happening on october the 11th
so all right let me send you out this
week with
this blessing go with confidence
into the days ahead trusting in god's
unfailing love and faithfulness god will
not abandon you you are the word of his
hands
his own creation and his love
endures forever so go in the joy
to love and serve the lord see you next
time
you